For the theoretical component of this course there's no required textbook.
It is recommended, however, that you have access to some solid operating system
textbook as an additional reference.
There are a number of options out there from a variety of authors.
And there are also many books that are available online,
including with completely free content.
My personal favorites are the Silberschatz operating systems books,
often called the dinosaur books because of the dinosaur on the cover.
There is one that includes more detail, Operating System Concepts, and
then an abbreviated one, Operating System Concepts Essentials.
I also like the Tanenbaum textbook called Modern Operating Systems.
And to this one, I have personally contributed to the Linux case study chapter.
If you look online,
each of these books has a number of available online resources.
There's some slides for the chapters.
There's some free available text online.
And there are also affordable Kindle editions that are for rent even.
And there is also a lot of material that's freely available online.
There's one recent title prepared by Andrea and Remzi Arpaci-Disseai.
It's called Operating Systems Three Easy Pieces.
This is a good book and its content matched fairly well with the content that
we'll cover in this course.
For certain lectures, I will also provide you with specific references from
which the lecture content is drawn.
Mostly these will be research papers, and some of them can be quite old.
But they're still quite seminal works in computer science.
Less often there will be some tutorials, manuals on specific OS technologies, or
even technology surveys.
In any case, all of these resources will be linked to in the Instructor Notes or
in the Course Wiki online.
Finally, regarding the programming aspect of this course,
I said that you will be required to program in C in a Linux environment and
that your programming assignments will require multi threaded programming.
To help with these topics there are a number of resources online for
C programming, for threading libraries such as PThreads.
And we'll make sure to provide links to some such content with your
programming assignment